good afternoon everyone um i am
delighted to invite you all to the post
doc talk discussion
after
ismail's talk yesterday and uh
welcome uh to both janan and
jim woodward who is the discussant this
afternoon
um thai i would like to now turn it over
to you to formally introduce uh them
thank you thank you thanks professor
natarajan so
again you may recall from yesterday
those of you who had joined us that
professor ismael received her doctorate
from princeton university she was a
mellon fellow at stanford and taught at
the university of arizona before coming
to columbia she's held a number of
prestigious fellowships including an neh
fellowship at the national humanities
center a queen elizabeth ii research
fellowship from the australian research
council and fellowships from the
templeton foundation and the center for
advanced studies in behavioral science
at stanford
her conversant today is professor james
woodward distinguished professor in the
department of the history and philosophy
of science at the university of
pittsburgh
before coming to pittsburgh in the fall
of 2010 professor woodward was the j.o
and juliet cupley professor of
humanities at caltech
he's a fellow of the american academy of
arts and sciences a fellow of the
american association for the advancement
of science and a fellow at the center
for advanced study in the social and
behavioral sciences a position he held
actually from 2015 to 2016.
from 2010 to 2012 he served as president
of the philosophy of science association
in 2005 he was awarded uh an award for
making things happen and making things
happen aboard from the
lake
la cato sarge and lakata's um
award so we're very delighted to have
him and very much looking forward to the
post talk discussion
uh video of this will be available on
our inference project website in about a
week's time so without further ado
happy to turn it over to you jim
thank you
i would just like to request everyone
else to switch off their videos please
and their audios thank you very much
okay so shall i try to
get things started by initiating this
conversation
absolutely
okay
um so
one of the uh themes in in your talk
yesterday at least as i understood it uh
today was uh something like the
following that there are different ways
of
approaching the topic of causation and
cause of reasoning in philosophy
one way which is associated with um
kind of standard
analytic philosophy analytic metaphysics
etc is to ask such questions as
what is causation or
what is included in our concept of
causation and then you do if you're
doing the latter you do some sort of
conceptual analysis of
our concept of causation but there's an
alternative way of approaching the
subject of causation
you can ask
questions about the role that causation
plays in our lives how
causal reasoning and causal thinking
figures in
so to speak the psychological economy of
human agents you can ask that question
you can ask the question of what the
physical underpinnings so to speak of
causal thinking are that is what's the
worldly infrastructure or the things
that have to be true of the world
uh for uh calls and reasoning to be
successful um i would you you emphasized
i think both of these in your talk i
would add a third component uh which is
more normative in character there are
also questions about
um what are the strategies or procedures
that make causal reasoning or learning
uh about causal relationships from
certain kinds of data uh reliable and if
you're doing these latter things rather
than the analytic metaphysics project
things really look
look rather different um
they're different criteria
for success the whole focus is different
the focus is more
you know it's psychological
anthropological there if you're
interested in the normative aspects of
things there are uh connections with um
work and statistics on causal reasoning
uh work in machine learning and ai
uh on uh on causal learning
um uh etc etc um so i thought maybe one
way we could get started would
just talk a little bit about this
at least as i see a distinction between
these two ways of going at
this general topic of trying to
understand causation and causal
reasoning and then there's a further
question which i think is interesting
about whether
um if you do think that there's some
merit in this alternative way of
approaching things that i'm describing
uh whether that might be extended to
other uh notions that are a
philosophical interest
right so i'm in complete agreement with
you um about the latter project that
that's certainly the one that i've been
engaged in i think one of the things
that happens when
you're doing the kind of standard
analytic metaphysics
approach is that you start with a
conceptual analysis with
you know what
what you what
what causation looks like from a
conceptual point of view and then you
look in the world that is the world is
described by physics and you try to see
whether there's anything that satisfies
that description and very often
precisely because the subject and the
relationship between the subject
and the world has kind of gone out of
view you don't find anything that's that
directly satisfies that description so i
think it's not only that there are these
two alternative projects but there's
there's a way in which the former
project is kind of bound to fail that
comes into view when you're doing the
latter kind of project
um the part that i didn't talk about the
you know the part
where you're treating it as a normative
you're look you're looking for sort of
normative guidance about things like you
know causal search
and inference strategies that's not
something that i talked about at all
it is something that you talk a lot
about in your new book which i you know
and i wonder if if you don't mind just
taking a couple of minutes to talk about
that since the book isn't out um and
i've had a peek at some of it i think
people would be really interested to
hear
sort of something about that okay well
well well thank you so the book is
called uh causation with a human face
um
normative theory and descriptive
psychology and it's forthcoming with
oxford in uh the middle the middle of
october
um and so what i try to do in the book
it's a a mixture of a lot of different
things
but one of the central projects or
themes is to try to bring together
what i think of as normative work about
causation and causal reasoning and i see
this going on as i said earlier in
statistics in
machine learning machine discovery
of
causal relationships and i also actually
think a fair amount of the philosophical
work that's been done on causation is
really
um the best way to understand it is as
normative proposals of various kinds so
there's a certain um tendency i think
particularly in analytic metaphysics to
think that the
project is somehow some kind of
descriptive one purely descriptive one
that is description either of our
concept of causation or maybe a
description of as they let people in
this tradition like to say causal
reality or what causation is and i think
putting things that way uh faces what
what in fact is a is a kind of normative
component the normative component being
that these are actually proposals about
how you want to reason think about
causation they're not just purely
descriptive so anyway there's this
normative um
component that comes out of the
disciplines that i just described and
then there's a
huge burgeoning amount of work
going on in
cognitive psychology developmental
psychology
to some extent in the animal learning
literature
there's work in uh primatology
um etc which is and to some extent also
neurobiology which is descriptive of of
the sorts of um
things that go on that when people
engage in causal reasoning
the kinds of causal judgments people
make the
procedures uh
cognitive and otherwise that they go
through
uh when they um
uh make make causal judgments and one of
the things that i try to do in the book
is to bring these two literatures
together and one of the ways in which i
think they can be brought together
is if you're willing to adopt um what
might be described as a kind of rational
actor
uh
model of
causal cognition and the basic idea here
and this fits with the general theme
that
causation is this functional notion that
we use
all the time in our daily lives um the
idea is that uh people um
when they engage in causal reasoning are
are often successful
uh they do things that um
in uh at least to some extent and in
some respects are normatively
appropriate
so you can you can then
connect the normative and the
descriptive by asking such questions as
well
a normative theory says that the
appropriate way to reason in such and
such a situation is so-and-so let's go
look and see whether people actually in
fact reason in that way and a whole lot
of psychology experiments have exactly
this form and you do see
a certain amount of you know rationality
or normatively appropriate behavior
in
people's causal reasoning you can also
go in the other direction
if you find people doing
something regularly
in their causal cognition
and you don't you have a theory that
suggests that it's
either completely normatively
inappropriate or maybe your theory says
nothing at all about whether it's
normally appropriate at all then that
can provide an impetus to ask the
question well maybe we should rethink
our normative theory a little bit you
know maybe um
uh we're missing something uh uh in the
um on our normative account so i see
these kind of back and forth
interactions uh going on between the um
uh the normative and the descriptive um
as i try to emphasize in the book this
isn't a matter of
you know deriving an art from an is or
anything like that um it's rather that
the um if you're willing to make
appropriate additional assumptions like
for example the rational actor
assumption then you can you can connect
uh the normative and descriptive so
that's
that is one of the themes in the book
and obviously my focus on the psychology
of causal inference is very much uh in
the spirit of kind of
putting the subject or the human agent
uh
back into the picture the the focus is
on at least in part on what we try to do
with causal reasoning but what we're in
um you know you know what
what is it what are the goals what are
the functions what is it we're trying to
accomplish
uh uh when when we uh engage in calls
and reasoning so that's
um uh that's one theme in the book
another theme in the book just just very
quickly is um
a certain skepticism about the um
tendency in at least a lot of
contemporary analytic philosophy to make
a very sharp distinction between
metaphysics and epistemology um you
certainly see this to some extent in
the analytic metaphysics literature on
causation and being on a lot of other
topics where the idea is that what
causation is uh should be understood in
some way that's totally divorced from
how we might find out about it
and this
for reasons that i uh you can perhaps
guess that i won't try to go into them
in detail now that strikes me as a
you know not a very uh
fruitful way of approaching the subject
okay um so another
theme in in your um discussion in your
uh yesterday uh jan was
what might be called the uh
the worldly inter underpinnings or the
physical infrastructure that underlies
uh causal reasoning and you i take it
you emphasize in particular the
uh the role of uh you know something
like uh
uh
thermodynamic gradients and so on and
the way in which um uh human agents are
situated in in time and in this
uh entropy uh uh gradient um
could you say a little bit more about
that and maybe also just about the whole
project of um
talking about um physical
uh underpinnings i i myself have some
thoughts about that and i'm i'm actually
working on a paper with some other
people uh in connection with that but
it's a and i think it's an interesting
project and it's obviously again rather
different from asking uh well what
belongs to the concept of causation and
what doesn't
it's more like you know what are the
preconditions that have to be present in
the world for uh
causal reasoning to be possible and
successful
right yeah so the way i mean the way it
sort of comes up in the philosophy of
physics literature is that for
some time just you know in the in the
kind of con
in the course of doing physics it became
clear that there were these high level
generalizations captured in
thermodynamics
that had to be in some way reconciled
that because they incorporated temporal
asymmetry had to be in some way
reconciled
with the underlying time symmetric
physical laws and what it means to say
that the underlying laws are time
symmetric it means that for any
physically possible trajectory that goes
from you know
from a state at time t1 to a state at
time t2 there's a physically possible
reverse of that trajectory so one that
goes from from
state s2 at t2
sorry from s2 which is the final state
in the original to the initial state in
the original but of course we look
around us and we see all sorts of
temporarily asymmetric processes
it became
uh sort of widely accepted that all of
the temporally asymmetric processes that
we actually see
are the ones that are captured by the
second law of thermodynamics there's
some
uh there might be some wiggle room about
that but they capture by far the largest
body of the temporally asymmetric
physical phenomena
in the world so the project of
reconciling the second law of
thermodynamics was the time symmetric
underlying laws was for a long time just
a straightforward physics project one
that took a long time there were a lot
of kind of missteps in the early history
of thermodynamics but probably in the
last 50 or 60 years it really became
started to you know come into focus
okay now when we look at agents and in
particular the first person kind of
perspective on the world from the point
of view of an embedded agent we find two
very striking asymmetries that are kind
of pervasive
from a first person point of view one is
the asymmetry of knowledge and the other
there's a causal asymmetry the asymmetry
of knowledge is this idea that um
you know we remember them sorry we
remember the past we don't remember the
future we know more about the past we
then we do about the future it takes
some time to actually give a precise
characterization of these we take that
as a rough and ready go the other one is
obviously the causal asymmetry the idea
that we think that from a first person
point of view we think that we can
affect the future by acting somewhere in
the here and now but not the past and
the question arose quite naturally
[Music]
are those in some way connected to the
asymmetry of thermodynamics right but
a quick question though uh janan um
you know the
there's a fundamental difference between
the past and the present in in terms of
access to information right
that um
and that you cannot circumvent no matter
what right and that's of course tied to
the directionality of time and so on but
i mean is it useful to see it as about
being about information
rather than entropy or are they
interchangeable i'm just curious
um so i'll i mean these were the
questions that people were asking right
so
um the
the i think the most illuminating way to
understand it is to think in terms of
of what kind of information is there
available in the world
for an agent
of the kind that has access to its local
environment to use
if you ask the question that way then
you do
you do get a natural answer and the
natural answer is something like this
right so if you're just looking at the
macroscopic structure of the world i
mean this is the one i went over very
quickly during the talk but the slightly
more detailed answer is this if you're
looking at the macroscopic structure of
the world and you assume that an agent
only has sort of whatever you think
direct
access is and you think there's some
sort of direct perceptual um that is
there's some basic notion of information
that that comes from some sort of causal
channel with the world
um on on part of an agent those are the
perceptual channels if you take
information that's coming through that
channel and you ask yourself what can an
agent in a generic
physically you know a generic world that
obeys the newtonian laws what can an
agent like that know about the rest of
the world what can an agent that has
that kind of you know contemporary
causal contact with its own local
environment parlay into in terms of
knowledge of the rest of the world
assume just to be
um i mean you know to make it a kind of
in-principle question assume it knows
the physical laws
and ask what can it infer from local
information about its environment so you
say
what can it infer
as a matter of physical almost nothing
you know everything that it can infer
depends on what's going on in other
places it depends on
um
you know we know as a matter of physical
law that the total state of the world at
one time if it's known
um can allow an agent that knows the
physical laws to know everything about
the past and future but we also know
that anything less than that it can know
almost nothing right
um but but now
if you take uh the statistical posture
of thermodynamics
you know the kind of the ordinary
canonical probability distribution that
the world is in a given microstate given
its macro state and you add that and now
you ask well what could it know from the
physical laws together with probability
distribution again the answer is almost
nothing if you think about it carefully
you'll see well of course that's because
if i'm just looking at my local
environment here and i'm asking what's
going to happen a day or a month from
now everything depends on the exogenous
influences that are going to impact
between now and then i mean literally
everything you can take any state you
know at any finite fraction
of uh or take any events or any finite
fraction of an interval into the future
you can find a solution to the physical
laws in which that event happens and
that event doesn't and you just by
putting the right exogenous influences
in same in the backward direction and
you know it's going to be the same in
the backward direction because the laws
are time symmetric
but if you add a low entropy initial
state
a low entropy state sometime in the
distant past
things change completely now anything
now an agent that's situated looking at
its local macroscopic environment who
has access only to the macroscopic
states of things around it can know a
whole lot about the past why is that
because for any or semi-ordered state of
its environment
given a low entropy past you know a low
entropy state in the distant past it can
infer a lot about what happened
between that distant past state and the
state of the system now that's kind of
that's the physical underpinnings
um of what's going on when you look at a
state like you know uh
uh you know a scar in a tree trunk or a
footprint in us in the sand or you know
a half a half empty a half melted
ice cube in a glass of water what you're
doing is effectively you're inferring
from its current state and knowledge
that it must be decaying from some lower
entropy state in the past
that at some point somebody put
you know it was in a more ordered state
than it is right now
so that's what that's what's really
going on in connecting sort of the
enteropic gradient with the kind of
information that's available to an agent
to use and you know to kind of parlay
into information about what's going on
at other times patently time asymmetric
has more to do now i mean it it that's
the step that that lets you go from
something about entropy to something
about knowledge or information
did that answer your question for you
yeah thank you yeah
um
now i've forgotten what the thread was
that we were talking about yeah well the
uh in general the uh the worldly in
underpinnings of uh
uh oh right
also reasoning and uh inference um i
would
want to add uh some other uh
possibilities that i think are
maybe also part of the worldly
underpinnings and i don't
myself understand very clearly how these
might be related to um
the thermodynamic gradient and entropy
increase and so on um and uh you know
perhaps you might help me with that so
one
general uh uh
feature which seems to be
uh
present and uh in our world and is
incorporated in a whole lot of physical
reasoning is some sort of notion of uh
the effective independence often enough
of uh incoming uh physical
in in incoming influences so to speak so
we don't for example you know if you're
if you have a uh
an accelerating uh electrical charge you
imagine
uh that it will uh uh radiate uh
outwards
with a uh you know a spherical uh wave
of electromagnetic radiation you don't
imagine that you're going to see
such a wave front uh
coming in from a distance and collapsing
on itself uh into a point and and the
idea is that the in the second cases
would require some you know fantastic
level of coordination between what we
think of as uh
independent uh uh causal influences and
that
uh you know at least in most cases um
you know
doesn't happen in nature now in that for
in that particular case i take it that
there is
some sort of connection with the um
the same kind of physical reasoning that
that
underpins the second law of
thermodynamics and so on the you know
the kinds of assumptions that boltzmann
made about uh
you know uh
uh
uncorrelated lists of molecular motions
immediately prior to collision and so
forth you can see see the connection
there but but i think that's just one of
the things that
is among these underpinnings of physical
reasoning and a couple of other things
that
strike me as
also present
are the following um one is simply that
a lot of physical systems have a certain
kind of modularity to them in the sense
that you can um
you don't really have to take into
account everything
in
what's going on in the external
environment uh in understanding uh uh
their behavior
and um
this is probably and probably the right
way to think about this is it's a kind
of uh you know in the in the physicist
jardin jargon a kind of effective
independence or effective modularity it
isn't that the
external influences aren't there at all
it's just that they're very small and
they can be neglected or maybe if they
need to be taken
into account uh they can be taken into
account uh just by talking about some
very small number of uh variables and
parameters that are on the you know that
you think it is on the boundary of the
system
you don't have to model everything in
the environment in detail in other words
to get the behavior of the system so it
just seems that a lot of physical
systems in our world are like that
um another
uh notion that strikes me as important
is is
the presence of what i
have called in a couple of papers um uh
approximate uh realization independence
or approximate uh conditional causal uh
independence where the idea is that at
least for
many systems
you don't have to know
the details of the physics all the way
down
to
understand their macro behavior
so um uh leo kadenov and uh nigel
goldenfeld give the example of uh
modeling the behavior of a bulldozer and
they say well you don't need to uh bring
in quantum chromodynamics to uh
understand the behavior of a bulldozer
um you can model it at
you know at
a much higher level now you could
imagine an alternative world in which uh
to model anything at all you had to
understand the physics at the very very
deepest level and of course that would
be a world which would be very difficult
to do
to do science or learn about
relationships in nature but our world
doesn't seem to be like that there's a
kind of you know a dec
proximate decoupling often between
different scales um and i think that's
also uh
something that facilitates uh cause of
reason in our world and i'm not sure
um exactly how these are related to the
second law it isn't obvious to me that
they all just sort of fall out of the
second second law and i wonder if you
have some thoughts about that
okay so there's a lot there uh so first
on the um
the microscopic sort of chaos in
macroscopic order so that's the full
statement actually of the past
hypothesis so you assume that it's a low
entropy initial state so there's
macroscopic order but other than that
you assume uncorrelated
uh microcondition
okay
um on the modularity so this is an
interesting
but can i can i just stop you for a
second
in connection with the past hypothesis
and i have to admit i've never
quite understood the
ins and outs of that um you know if
you're just you know modeling the
behavior you know of a gas or something
that it's the non-equilibrium state and
it's going to equilibrium it doesn't
seem like you have to bring the
paths hypothesis directly into the
picture you all you have to do is to
talk about the
you know the uh the st
the
uh state of the gas
uh at the moment and then you make um
you know assumptions about unquiet
lateness or
uh you know equal probability over all
the microstates consistent with the
macro state and so on and so forth so
that's in inferring its future and
ensuring its past you need to pass
hypothesis okay okay so if you just
think of it in time symmetric terms
because the laws are time symmetric
probability possibilities is time
symmetric
so if you take those things and evolve
them forward you're going to get exactly
the same results as if you take those
things and evolve them backward so if
you if you didn't have the past
hypothesis you ought to infer not only
that the system
if it's a gas with you know partly
partly collected in one corner you have
to infer not only is the system just
running the dynamical laws forward gonna
go to an increasingly dispersed state
you have to inferring backward assume
that's also coming from a dispersed
state so that in fact is collapsing
um into a lower entropy stage just a
chance fluctuation the probability
distribution yields
so the past hypothesis is an hypothesis
that when you're inferring that when
you're kind of retrodicting rather than
predicting
it's a group postulate that gets you the
right state in the distant past right
i'll just say one more thing that
connects with our previous um the talk
about information that's also needed to
get things like that a semi-ordered
state of the environment is in fact a
record
of
a more ordered state in its distant past
because otherwise the right thing to say
when you see a footprint is in the sand
is not that someone stepped there
but that in fact it was a chance
fluctuation from
um a a beach
at higher entropy that's the idea
yeah i don't know to what extent our
audience is interested in the status of
the past hypothesis and as i say i'm
certainly now
expert
but i have to say that one of the things
that i find a little puzzling uh about
the kind of
inference that you just described is
that
it it sounds as though
the claim is that we have to assume the
past hypothesis
if we're to take um what appear to be
records of the past uh you know as
reliable
at all
but
i take it we we do have records of
the early universe
we
think anyway that we have some kind of
physical understanding of why it's
plausible that the early universe was in
a low entropy state and this has to do
with complicated considerations about uh
the role of gravity and uh
uh the very early universe so
it sounds as though we we
at least in cosmology and i'd actually
be interested in what priya thinks about
this
um
we think that we have information about
the past
of the early universe and its low
entropy state that is um
uh
it it it seems like we're assuming we
have kind of some kind of independent
access to that that doesn't uh require
uh use of the past hypothesis can i say
something yes maybe i'm just confused
but that's my reaction so i wouldn't put
it in epistemic terms that's certainly
the way that that albert presents it
this is something that we have to
suppose in order for our records to make
sense i would say rather look we live in
a world in which records are possible
because the world started out in a low
entropy state and all of the things that
you're talking about are inferences from
current states from the current state
yeah i agree with janan i think that
would be the point of view that i would
take too yeah
okay well that i mean that that is fine
with me that makes perfect sense uh
as far as i'm concerned the one way to
see it is to say look if we found out
that there was no past hypothesis we'd
need to find new foundations for all of
those inferences
because records would no longer be
underwritten the right inference that
to
the right inferences to make from
everything that we see
will have been undermined how would we
find out that there is no past
hypothesis presumably
wouldn't that require somehow finding
out that the
universe apparently wasn't in a low
entropy state or at least wasn't in the
kind of low entropy state
that is described by the past hypothesis
and wouldn't that in turn uh require
already taking seriously our records of
the past
we would i mean all of this is just
making explicit that on which all of our
theoretical knowledge rests any
inference from present data to what it
tells us about the past in one way or
another rests on the past hypothesis so
when i said you know if we found out i
meant if you released your commitment to
the idea that there was a past
hypothesis all of those inferences would
no longer be underwritten
it's like you have a source of
information so this is the right way to
think or at least the way that i think
of it
is
is making explicit the commitments
the physical commitments
on which your reliance on records rests
and all of our theoretical knowledge of
the you know all of our
the information not only you know our
direct inferences about the past
but um
but the things that we treat as the
evidence for our theories
depends on being able to read
the macro state of systems as records
of their past
yeah i guess i mean one question i would
have in this connection is
how
i i understand that when that if the
universe were
in its past in a very different state
than in fact was
uh we wouldn't have records and
all or they wouldn't be accurate we
wouldn't have human agents etc etc but i
guess the question is how sensitive the
kinds of inferences you're describing
are to the exact details of the
past hypothesis
uh that that's
um i mean it's there i mean you know i
mean and if i take it if the universe uh
somehow began or was in a very early
state
of a complete thermodynamic uh
equilibrium then
we wouldn't be here
etc etc there would be nothing that
would be recognizable as of any interest
anyway as a as a record uh uh et cetera
et cetera
but that the fact that
the universe began in a low entropy
state or it didn't begin in a complete
um
you know equilibrium state that seems uh
a little more generic than
the kinds of assumptions that go into
the vast hypothesis
did you want to
yeah i mean um yeah i
i don't know if um there
there are alternatives actually in terms
of
just the frameworks that are available
for calculation
um
i don't really know what we would um
what alternatives we would have if we
didn't start from that generic uh
assumption
well i'm i'm not challenging the generic
presumption i was just wondering about
the
whether we have to assume anything as
specific as the
past hypothesis in
the david albert sense
it's not that specific actually
yeah i think it's uh it's i find it a
little more sweeping um the
past hypothesis
and but i uh and i know i agree with
janan's way of phrasing it rather than
david's
um but i think
part of the you know i you know tried
one can think about it in sort of the
counter factual right so
what would have happened i mean the
thing is you immediately run aground if
you did not start from this so you know
the counter factual way is not an
effective way to understand this in this
case right because you very quickly will
reach the point of
the so we wouldn't be here to ask this
question if that you know this this that
had not happened right so
yeah
and the very theories that we use to
um you know sort of guide our sense of
those sorts of counterfactuals is itself
based on theory uh based on
evidence inferences from which rests on
the past hypothesis so everything would
be up for grabs yeah i was going to say
then everything
becomes you know up for grabs right so
yeah i mean
it's a hard one i mean this is a really
difficult uh question so
i mean one one way to ask it would be
and this i mean this isn't at all
implausible that you know sort of
uh our theoretical knowledge progresses
to
um to a stage where we now have a very
specific idea of what kind of initial
state that the universe was in
i think what albert is doing is saying
in order to underwrite the sorts of
asymmetries that are embodied in our
causal reasoning and our inferences to
the past and something we need something
that looks generically like
a state of macroscopic order
in the past or some sort of boundary
condition that will restrict
the states in the past
in such a way that those inferences will
be underwritten yeah you need a
curtailment of the number of possible
states initial states from which you
could start
they could be a set it doesn't have to
be unique but i mean there could be a
set of them
but i think um i find it quite difficult
to understand even how we could explore
the what that set could be because you
very quickly run into the um
uh moving forward that you know we
wouldn't be here to question blah blah
for many of even those other
possibilities right so
it's pretty hard to delimit that set as
well
does that help
jim
yeah i i mean i don't know whether we
want to continue on this topic but i
guess
one of the things that that strikes me
and um
i i talk about this in the
paper on the flagpole that you may
uh know about is that if in for example
uh recent work in machine learning
on um calls learning causal direction so
what
you know the the the paradigm is
something like this you have two
correlated variables
um you have a purely observational data
that shows that they're correlated
you can somehow exclude the possibility
that they have a common cause but you
don't know whether x causes y or y
causes x
um
even in that apparently uh very
unfavorable setting
uh there are in fact um
uh algorithms and strategies that will
allow you to infer
uh causal direction with a fairly high
level of reliability
and what these procedures do
is that they uh exploit the fact that in
this kind of setup
there is almost
it's
at least in a whole lot of cases it's
going to be possible to find
an additional variable
call it z
which for example may be
uncorrelated with x
but correlated with y or alternatively
uncorrelated with y
but correlated with x
and then you can exploit that fact to
reach the correct conclusion about
causal direction so the the um uh
the correct uh direction is the
direction in which you have a you know a
sort of uh
collider type structure in which the uh
the two uncorrelated variables are
causes in the uh
uh of of of the uh of of the other
variable now in that kind of setup
you're you're exploiting uh the fact
that there's
a certain amount of uncorrelatedness or
exogeneity uh out there but it's all
very local you're not um you know
bringing now maybe in you know at the
end of the day it all depends on the
past hypothesis i don't know but you're
certainly not um
uh kind of directly uh making use of
anything
like the vast past hypothesis you're
making use of stuff that is very as i
say very very very very local to the uh
system that you're um
uh uh uh reasoning uh
about
and um
i i guess i just think it's of interest
to try to understand how those
inferences work and what their what
their warrant is and what they assume
about what's
uh true of the systems that uh you're
using this methodology to investigate
um
and you can do all of that i think
without uh
necessarily bringing the past hypothesis
i mean i'm sorry
may i ask you a question from the
audience that's what i was wondering
about you from paul geha um how is the
past hypothesis different from the
second law of thermodynamics would both
of you please explain
can i um can i say something just
before i lose i said that
i mean one thing that you have to keep
in mind and i will come back to that
question okay thank you um jim is that
that
you know when people are in
looking
for foundations of thermodynamics in
particular the kind of project
that um
albert's engaged in
um we're dealing with
deterministic laws so any assumption
that you can state in local terms will
ultimately be
stateable in terms of kind of first
principles from initial conditions
so in a way what he's trying to do is
chase those
assumptions back what he calls it the
mother of all
you know sort of assumptions that you
need to make to generate all of the sort
of local that i mean that the aspiration
is though i don't i mean you know if you
ask me to give you a proof that it's
going to work this way but the
aspiration is it's going to be a single
assumption that's going to underwrite
all of those more local inferences so
what you're asking is well i don't see
that in all of these more local
inferences we're actually making any
necessary reliance on the past
hypothesis i'm saying that might be true
as a matter of psychological factors
matter of practice but what
what albert is trying to do is precisely
look at all of
all of the kind of local assumptions
that we make and that underwrite things
like inferences from records and
scientific practice and see if we can
chase those all the way back to a single
assumption about what the initial
conditions were like and it's gonna be
there's gonna there ought to be i mean
it's
it's contingent whether there's some
simply stateable
um
principle about the initial conditions
that will do that but there's going to
be
some
assumption about the initial conditions
because the laws are deterministic in
this regime
that we'll be able to capture
all of those what you need to underwrite
all of the local inferences
yeah i mean i guess the only thing i
would say is that if
david albert wants to make claims like
that then uh with all due respect you
should actually be looking at
these local procedures in detail and
then telling us in some detail how
they're
uh connected to the past hypothesis uh i
i'm not claiming that that is uh
impossible at all i'm just saying that
uh well there's a project there and how
um that might be done is not uh at least
to me uh uh uh straightforward and i
guess i should answer the question of
the the person
and then we'll because there's so much
more to say about this and i my
inclinations to come back and say more
but we should also ask answer the
question that uh well i haven't been
looking at what was it ty
sure um how is the past hypothesis
different from the second law of
thermodynamics
do you want me to answer that
please you or both i'll do it quickly
um so second law of thermodynamics says
that no system decreases in its entropy
the past hypothesis is an hypothesis
that is supposed to generate the second
law of thermodynamics in conjunction
with the fundament with the
newtonian mechanical laws and the
statistical postulate
does that answer the question
uh paul did you want to
type anything else up okay yes thank you
jim before now i am going to come back
in fairness to david albert i mean this
stuff is all um
this stuff is all
very much in progress and what david was
trying to do is to to make explicit you
know at what's really a very preliminary
qualitative level
but much better than anybody had done
before the kind of thing that you need
um
you know to to at least get going on
something that looks like um it would
underwrite retrospective as well as
prospective
inferences but you're absolutely right
and i think he would be happy to
acknowledge that ultimately the goal is
to try to understand all kind of you
know reasoning um
in terms in terms of something that we
can connect directly and explicitly to
um
to the causal asymmetries captured in
thermodynamics what what's surprising
about thermodynamics is the degree to
which an incredibly diverse
uh you know body of phenomena all of the
temporarily asymmetric phenomena you see
when you look around you fall under the
scope of the second law if if you can
you know sort of understand even in
qualitative terms how the second law can
underwrite something like causal
reasoning which does have built into it
may be the most fundamental kind
of of temporal asymmetry
than
then you've done something and that's
what he was trying to do
what about the other uh
candidates for physical underpinnings uh
that i mentioned like right i wanted to
calculate modularity and realization
independence do you see those also as uh
no i so let me actually so but first
priya you came up for a second it seemed
like you might have something to add
here
no no no not at all i was just nodding
in agreement yeah
um
so so i i now we are leaving david i
don't know what he thinks about this the
modularity question is one that i have
found um very interesting and so i'm
just now gonna
give completely speculative uh idea sort
of musings on that so one thing to say
is it's for sure true that just looking
around us you know the systems that we
actually see and i'm not going to say in
our universe but those systems that we
see around us in the biosphere are not a
random selection of all physically
possible systems that there are so
you're absolutely right that there's no
reason that just looking at the
fundamental laws they should exhibit the
kind of modularity that we in fact find
in many of the systems around us and
moreover those tend to be the kinds of
systems that are targets for scientific
explanation and that are moreover you
know targets for the things like you
know the formulation of laws or at least
the you know the searching for dynamical
regularities in their behavior we do not
try to sit down and write down the
dynamics of janan's right thumb and
priya's earlobe and right we don't do
that so the real question is why looking
around us do we find all these kinds of
do we a fine systems like that
you know
and at a much higher
proportion than you would expect if you
just thought that that the systems
around us were a random selection of
possible configurations of matter
in the bias for the obvious answer is
that there's a lot of evolutionary
pressure towards stable you know finding
systems that right so there's a
contingency right there's an evolution
it's all contingent on evolutionary
outcomes right um
right
so if you imagine i mean you know you
imagine the world is throwing up complex
systems of all kinds most of those are
going to disperse some of those are some
some combination of self-organization
selection is going to generate systems
that because of the regularity of the
exhibit and the fact that they they
largely managed to despite the kind of
onslaught of exogenous influences to
which their subject at any given moment
managed to maintain their internal
integrity and do it that they need to
persist those are the systems that we're
going to find around us
but um yeah quickly to uh
to ask for a clarification but
isn't the implicit in the way you
phrased it the fact that
evolution whatever
there were multiple potentially an
infinite number of outcomes
and because of evolutionary pressure
only some particular ones have survived
but that does not mean that all those
outcomes were not manifested they've
just not survived in time
they they've not persisted as you said
right but the other outcomes
might well have i mean we have to leave
explanatory room for the fact that each
one of them all the possibilities were
manifest right right we don't um we
don't know otherwise
i mean well we know it's finite and it's
not infinite and so on so forth but um
um
yeah i'm fine i'm finding it a little
confusing like if we ask the question of
the biosphere
should we just retreat and say well
every possible
state
for a system like a plant that evolves
like you know the fig tree that looks
like this today there were many many
there were an infinite variety or a
finitely large number of variety in
which you know fig leaves were made and
then they just did not survive the
evolutionary pressure so when we talk
about outcomes and things should we
say that everything is possible or i
mean should we operate from that basis
or should we already operate from the
fact that that we have an explanation
there's some explanatory power and
evolution that not all possibilities
were actually actualized and only finite
number or one or whatever
yeah i to me it seems like that's a
fundamental
distinction you want to make because
if
one of them allows it's almost like
anything goes explanatory power and the
other is a very directed
particular kinds of explanatory power
um
am i being confused about something else
i don't know i i'm kind of going around
in circles trying to see
how we would how we need to see the
setup
tim did you have something
oh well i
i mean i do think that you know looking
at the matter from the point of view of
a biologist
the biologist does have some sort of
conception of what's
biologically possible
and it's it's a it's a smaller subset
than uh
the set of all uh uh uh physical
possibilities so i mean there i think i
i mean that's just part of i take it
what
you know how the
i mean the biologist may not regard him
himself or herself as restricted to
the forms of life that um
have actually ever existed in the past
because you know there's
certainly a lot of current work in
biology involves you know creating new
biological structures that have never
existed in the past but i think there is
some sort of uh broader constraint
having to do with a biological
uh possibility and it's a more
constrained set than
uh just what's physically possible so
but to get back to the the question of
um
you know why do we find modular systems
um
i i agree that part
in nature i think part of the answer to
the question is in so far as we're
concerned with biological systems it has
a whole lot to do with
uh the operation of natural selection
and i think that's actually connected to
the
uh issue about realization independence
too because
these systems
typically the um
the futures of their environment that
are important for um
you know purposes of survival and
reproduction are at least somewhat
macroscopic or coarse-grained
features of the environment and so the
organism is sensitive to those
and maybe not to more fine-grained
details and that means that in modeling
the organism we only have to look at the
coarse grained features of the
environment and the coarse grain
features of the organism itself rather
than more fine-grained details so you
know if i
um
if i'm a
uh
an early hominid i want to be responsive
to the fact that there's a
a large predator uh nearby me
uh but i uh
i don't have to make fine-grained
discriminations about the uh
exact
configuration of the molecules
in that
siberian tiger or whatever it is
uh that is approaching me and then in
addition to that there you know there
are things about stability and so on and
you know in the
you know in in in the human nervous
system you don't want um
the operation of our brains to be
incredibly sensitive to uh you know
small uh
uh quantum mechanical fluctuations and
so on and so forth and so we have you
know natural selection has ensured that
that's not the case so in in the case of
biological organisms i think you do have
a story
about natural selection also just about
you know the our size as it were
uh uh that our scale that um
uh explains why you get some kind of
modularity and realization independence
it might be that the correct story about
those things for non-biological systems
has to be a little bit different i don't
know
can i add something to that though
because it
it nests right with what you were saying
if you ask and this is something that i
wondered about
for a while too if you ask is there some
increase in fitness
that one would get by being able to see
right down to the microscopic fabric of
the world and in particular episemic
fitness would it add to my ability to
predict macroscopically
if i had microscopic rather than merely
macroscopic access to the systems in my
environment it turns out for reasons
that are directly connected to the past
hypothesis that the answer is no
and the answer is no precisely because
of the microscopic
so one of the interesting and important
and profound things and and
surprising things about thermodynamics
is the one that you pointed to there's
no reason to think from first principles
that there should be any kind of
prediction at the macro level that
wasn't sensitive to microscopic
the fact that there are
that there is there are laws of
thermodynamics that is we can formulate
macroscopic generalizations that are
insensitive to the microscopic
underpinnings is surprising but it also
means because it means that they're
robust in the face of of
of you know whatever is going on
microscopically but it also means that
those are the very generalizations that
we rely on to predict the future
so having more information about the
microscopic
state is not going to be parlayable so
to speak into increased macroscopic
prediction about the future
right and and so you're arguing that
this is why sort of the modularity this
is where the modularity comes in that
you don't really need to know
to have descriptions for every possible
micros at the microscopic level for any
sort of macro
right dominant right
yeah i mean like that's clearly true and
i get that
the kind of reasoning you were
describing janan has a role to play in
that um but i'm wondering if i guess i'm
wondering if that's the whole
the whole story uh almost certainly not
no i think it doesn't have something to
do with
the character of the uh
the generalizations themselves that
uh uh the different levels okay so
you know i'm sure no no no i i think
you're you're assuming you're thinking
that everybody who's in this
in the discussion about thermodynamics
that it's far more developed than it is
i mean it's it's really everybody knows
that there's so many things that we're
only just beginning to get a bit of a
qualitative grip on
um but you're right i mean even
understanding that the the target
general you know the target explananda
much less the precise nature of the
thing that's going to be doing the
explanation and whether or not it's
something that we can um subsume under
the past hypothesis or completely open
questions i think almost everybody
would acknowledge that
so um if this is sort of a natural
moment to ask a
question um ty did you want to um read
out freddos's question
sure
um
this is he's quoting from causation with
the human face jim
there's no well-defined notion of an
intervention on the spin state of one of
the separated particle pairs with
respect to the other in epr type
experiments this would represent a
limitation on the application of an
interventionist account of causation and
quotation
so curtis is asking would either of you
care to address this dilemma if indeed
it is one and he says uh he adds i know
we're not discussing quantum
mechanics kim did you since that's from
you i'm happy to but i think probably
you're there well okay
so so that just to clarify that was from
a a paper of mine also with the title
causation with a human face written um
i don't know what
10 or 15 years ago
and i don't uh uh
and president subscribed to all of the
views about causation and physics that i
uh uh defended in that paper
um
uh
the paper's different from the
forthcoming book uh but i i will try to
say a little bit about this and the
question of whether this is in some
sense a limitation on uh broadly
interventionist conception of causation
um i don't think so um i mean one of the
things that is
clear in epr type setups is that
you cannot by um uh intervening on one
of the uh correlated uh particle pairs
uh uh causally influence the um
uh behavior of the other particle pair
okay this is a
you know kind of no no signaling uh uh
result
and um
so you don't you certainly don't want um
uh the
i would have thought the the outcome to
be that there's
the
correct way to think about the situation
to be that there's some causal
connection between the two separated
particle pairs that would you know that
would violate uh locality special
relativity uh uh etc etc so if it's
right that there's no well-defined
notion of an intervention that you can
carry out
uh on one of the pairs then the
interventionist account yields the
correct answer that there's no causal
connection there so i would see that as
a virtue of the interventionist account
not
a limitation but
i will defer to the experts on
quantum mechanics who will know more
about this subject
than i
i mean 100 agreement
and it goes very much with the idea that
you know that causal relations are part
of the surface fabric of the world
um and they're things that emerge you
know kind of when you have the right
sorts of relations between interventions
and outcomes
yeah i mean it's certainly uh at least
the way i'm thinking about things
and maybe janan too that it's an
implication of this whole way of
thinking about causation is that there
may very well be physical systems for
which
the kind of causal analysis that we're
you know
employ in
other kinds of contexts is just
inappropriate because the preconditions
for the application of that kind of
reasoning just aren't present in the
systems in question
so another question i thought we might
discuss janet unless someone else wants
to jump in and
discuss i don't i don't see anything jim
so go ahead and proceed here
so you and i are both
i think self-identified pragmatist of
one variety or another
um
could you say something janan about what
your version of
what what are the distinctive
commitments of your version of
pragmatism
and how does that how does it contrast
with other sorts of possibilities
i'm not you know i'm not sure that i
have any definite take on what sort of
pragmatist i am i tend to think that you
know we're natural creatures in the
natural world our minds are made us
allowed to
um our minds were made to allow us to
cope not copy as rorty famously said
and sort of many of the notions that we
use to represent the world even the ones
that are kind of psychologically most
basic for us in in in terms of how we
represent the world are just part of a
user interface that was designed to
optimize our chances of getting around
um
you know
to feeding and mating opportunities so
in that sense i'm a pragmatist
that sort of pragmatism i think is just
a consequence of naturalism
and it's one i was driven to you know
you know it's not it was never a first
principle for me it was more one that i
was driven to just by trying to
understand how to fit creatures into
creatures like us into the world as it's
described by physics and to reconcile
the kind of manifest image of the world
with the image that physics presents to
us
um
so that that's the way that i think of
it also i mean something else that that
you've brought up that that i think is
right which is
um
you know the need to bring the subject
back into description when we're trying
to understand
even the most basic notions that we use
to describe the world
and i mean sort of in physics i think
this becomes clear so i come at from a
very
you know i started out being a
fundamentalist about physics thinking
you know the world is the way that
physics describes it but there are all
these problems coming up in physics in
places where some feature of the world
some feature of our experience of the
world or the first person perspective of
the world or the everyday common sense
view of the world that's somehow not
locatable or findable in the in the view
of the world as it's described by
physics um
and in all of those cases or all
this fundamental thing right with
quantum physics which is the sort of the
the alleged clean separation between the
subject and the object the observer and
the observed
you know when that gets disrupted as
well right
right 100
yeah
so one finds that the the attempt to
give us or god's eye view of the world
fails in ways that demand that you bring
the subject back in
so i i had a
question that um
for both of you um you know this
question about everything about the
modularity that jim mentioned right that
you can restrict yourself to a certain
level macroscopic level
about you know i think it was the karen
of uh quotation that we said you know
you don't know need to know qcd to
understand how the bulldozer works
but i mean is that reflecting something
uh is that reflecting that the laws of
there does
is reductionism somewhere in there
about you know as a feature of the laws
i mean is that what it's about
um
are you asking jim
yeah yeah well um
so i i mean i'm not sure quite what you
mean by reductionism but i
i mean the way i think about it is it's
it it isn't that i'm not
and i assume this is the way that
kavanaugh
at all would think about it too it's not
as though you have sort of emergent new
physics at the bulldozer level
or something like that it's rather more
that you just don't have to take into
account
certain kinds of information
to
model
of the behavior of the
uh bulldozers so it's a it's a feature
of the of the world and our theorizing
that we can
uh sort of you know drop certain kinds
of information there's so some epistemic
sufficiency it is sufficient
to just know newton's laws
to understand what the bulldozer is
doing and you don't need to know qcd or
qed
right right
and i think this is this is related to
other
uh kind of kinds of generic facts
or
i guess really sort of semi-mathematical
facts um that
are uh
they're pertinent here and i mean
so you you can very often have a
situation with the following kind of
structure
at a very very fine-grained level
um
some set of variables are relatively
highly correlated with one another
but if you coarse grain in the right way
of course grain the variables
um you can produce
um outcomes where um
uh you you you have just a much smaller
uh number of variables to begin with
and you have um
lots of other stuff just becomes
independent as a consequence of the
quartz
um
uh so you i mean
one of the things that i see to be
characteristic of
causal inference is we're exploiting
independencies that exist in the world
both
statistical independencies and you know
other kinds of independencies of a more
causal
character
and
the notion of independence is very much
a notion that's tied to ideas about
level and scale
so something can be
um
if you're modeling an incredibly
fine-grained level
it can look as though everything is is
dependent on everything else as you move
to a more coarse-grained level uh you
can get that um
you get you get as i say a smaller
number of variables and you get other
stuff
uh in a way kind of effectively
irrelevant and effective here in the
sense in which uh a physicist i take it
would use
um uh uh the notion of uh all right so i
mean that's where this you know this
idea of an effective theory right so
that you can
you can treat some variables as
extraneous
um and then you can um
uh you can formulate um you can
understand the behavior with a pair down
number of variables that are independent
as you said and that they are sufficient
to give you
explanatory power predictive power
um
and and so on
um
yeah i think that's what i meant when i
was trying to say reduction you know you
reduce reductionism in um sort of an
implementation thereof yeah yeah that so
that's the sort of picture that i have
you're looking for what um a
statistician would call sufficient
statistics
where
uh you know you have something that is
much higher dimensional and you're
trying to
reduce it down to a smaller dimension
but the smaller dimension still um
retains the uh relevant information that
you need for uh understanding the macro
behavior that you happen to be
uh uh interested in
so that that's the that's the general uh
uh
general picture that i that i have and i
i must say that i mean philosophers have
uh of course
all sorts of ideas about
theory reduction and so forth i don't
really see that a lot of what the
philosophers have to say about theory
reduction
relates all that closely to what i just
described which seems like it's more
the relevant thing in
understanding how
theories at different levels or scales
are related to one another
let's see if something else showed up in
the show yeah i'm just scanning the chat
and um
i don't see any further questions from
the audience um so then i guess before
we close are there any final sort of
comments or thoughts that both of you
would like to share
thank you for having us
thank you very much
thank you so much to both of you for
taking the time and uh sharing um your
thoughts and
you know these are very very uh
important foundational questions and as
our audience probably realized that
there is no conclusion final answer
these are evolving in terms of how we
think and how we even frame the
questions right
how we frame them and pose them
so i just want to take this opportunity
to thank you both on behalf of the
frankie program and the inference
project
and i want to thank the audience for
being here on a saturday afternoon
so thanks very much and uh see you all
soon bye
bye bye thank you bye thank you